[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم تفجرت اشتباكات عنيفه بين وحدات
من الجيش اليمني ومسلحين حوثيين شمالي
العاصمه صنعاء وعلى بعد كيلومترات فقط من
منزل الر رئيس منظور هادي ياتي هذا فيما
اشار مصدر يمني الى ان الحوثيين انسحبوا
من وادي الغيل في محافظه الجوف وفق اتفاق
مع الجيش استثنى منطقه الساقيه نتوقف مع
هذا الخبر لنناقش في محورين ما هي دلالات
تحركات مسلحي الحوثيين في العاصمه صنعاء
وفي محافظه الجوف على الحدود مع
السعوديه وما هي خيارات الدوله اليمنيه
والقوى الداعمه لها في مواجهه هذه
التحركات
[موسيقى]
في محافظه الجوف على حدود اليمن مع
السعوديه انسحب الحوثيون من مناطق الغيل
كما انسحب منها الجيش اليمني واللجان
الشعبيه وفق اتفاق هدنه بين الجانبين اما
في شمال العاصمه صنعاء فقد حاول الحوثيون
التقدم الى عمق المدينه واندلعت اشتباكات
عنيفه بينهم وبين بعض وحدات الجيش اليمني
وقع هذا بينما قال جمال بن عمر مبعوث
الامين العام للامم المتحده انه اجرى ما
سماها محادثات ايجابيه مع عبد الملك
الحوثي حول سبل حل الازمه من جانبه كشف
الرئيس اليمني منصور هادي ان قيادات
عسكريه مازالت تتلقى توجيهات من الرئيس
المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح كما اشار الى
عرض ايرانيا مشروط لممارسه ضغوط على
الحوثيين بينما يجري الوسيط الاممي جمال
بن عمر مباحثات مع زعيم الحوثيين في صعده
شمالي اليمن ويبرم اتفاق على انسحاب
متبادل بين الحوثيين والجيش من الغيل في
محافظه الجوف المحاذيه للسعوديه تزداد
الجراه العسكريه لمسلح الحوثي في العاصمه
صنعاء مواجهات مع الجيش قرب بيت الرئيس
عبد ربو منصور هادي نفسه وفي منطقه شملان
وغيرها مع تقدمهم على طول شارع الثلاثين
ومهاجمتهم معسكرا للجيش جنوبي العاصمه قل
وجرح العشرات معظمهم
مدنيون والوضع هكذا يقول الرئيس اليمني ان
قائد المنطقه السادسه ياتمر باوامر الرئيس
المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح وذلك وفق ما
قاله مصدر رفيع لمراسل الجزيره في
اليمن عندما سقطت محافظه عمران في ايد
الحوثيين في يوليو 2014 تحدث محللون عن
تواط قيادات عسكريه وفيه للرئيس المخلوع
الذي يتهم ايضا بان له يدا مع الحوثيين
وقد نفى هو ذلك الكلام بشده ووصف مروج
بالجبناء بل نقلت مواقع اخباريه يمنيه خبر
كشف ضباط في الجيش يكونون يعملون لمصلحه
الحوثي هل ذلك من اسباب تهديد الرئيس عبد
الربو منصور هادي باللجوء الى تشكيل
اللجان الشعبيه لطرد الحوثيين المسلحين من
صنعاء والى اين يؤدي اجراء كهذا ببلاد في
كل بيت منها اكثر من قطعه السلاح وهل يغير
تهديده بطلب التدخل الدولي من الامر شيئا
ماذا عن التدخل الاقليمي اذ علم مراسل
الجزيره ان وسيطا عمانيا نقل للرئيس
اليمني عبد الربو منصور هادي مطالبه
ايرانيه بالتنازل عن محاكمه المتهمين في
قضيه السفينتين جهان واحد وجهان اثنين
التين ضبطته السلطات في الحديده وعدن وهما
تحملان اسلحه للحوثيين مقابل ذلك تضغط
ايران على الحوثي ليسحب مخيمات الاعتصام
لا سما من جنوب صنعاء لكن هل فضل الاعتصام
والمظاهر المس
تد موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
صنعاء محمود ياسين الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
ومن بيروت عبد حافظ معجب الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي كما ينضم الينا من جده عبر سكايب
الكاتب والمحلل الاستراتيجي الدكتور علي
بن حسن التوتي مرحبا بكم سيد
معجب يعني هذه سياسه سياسه الحوثيين سياسه
النط والمراوح من جبهه عسكريه الى اخرى من
خانه سياسيه الى اخرى وهذا التصعيد الخطير
في صنعاء يعني في الساعات الاخيره هل
لابقاء
الضغط لتحقيق مزيد من المكاسب والتنازلات
من قبل الحكومه ام هي بدايه معركه
صنعاء نعم ما يحدث في صنعاء اليوم كما
يعلم العالم اجمع بانها ثوره سلميه
واحتجاجات سلميه في مخيمات الاعتصام وهي
الامر الذي ازعج السلطه كثيرا ولكن هناك
من يحاول ان يجر هذه الاعتصامات وهناك من
يحاول ان يجر الحركه الحوثيه وان يجر
المواطنين الى مواجهات مسلحه والكل يعرف
بميليشيات التكفيريين الذين يتحركون اليوم
على مراه ومسمع ويعتدون على المواطنين
وبالتالي على المواطنين ان يدافعوا عن
انفسهم ومن الطبيعي جدا ان تكون هناك
مواجهات مسلحه لان التكفيريين عندما
يحملون السلاح على المواطنين بالتالي على
المواطنين ان يحملوا السلاح ايضا للدفاع
عن انفسهم ما يحدث اليوم في صنعاء هو دفاع
عن النفس ما يحدث اليوم في صنعاء هو ان
هناك طرف يستخدم المؤسسه العسكريه ويستخدم
الدوله لفرض خيارات معينه
ولجر الاعتصامات السلميه الى مواجهه
المسلحه ا سيد ياسين يعني في الوقت الذي
يتحدث فيه اليك هناك تصعيد كبير في في
صنعاء اخبار عن قصف مبنى التلفزيون
الحكومي وكذلك نقطه عسكريه بالقرب من من
المطار سؤالي ما مدى فاعليه الجيش اليمني
في مقاومه الحوثيين وسط انباء عن انسحاب
وحدات من الجيش في شملان مثلا شمالي صنعاء
هل هذا يعني ان الرئيس فقد نسبيا السيطره
على الجيش ام ان هناك اختراقات كبرى داخل
الجيش السؤال موجه لي نعم
طبعا اولا بسرعه وباقتراب يعني اريد ان
اقول انه ضحك كالبكا هذا الذي يقوله الاخ
الحوثي عن ان هذه هي الثوره السلميه اي
ثوره سلميه انا لا ادري ثوره سلميه نحن
جرنا الى العنف كيف تجر عربه ديناميت قدمت
من صعده الى محيط العاصمه وبدات تهدد حياه
الناس
وتضرب وضمن سياق عسكري متكامل لحركه
ميليشياوي تطلق القذائف على العاصمه
وتحاصرها وقريبا كما قلت من بيت الرئيس
الاخ الحوثي يتحدث
بشكل ثقه بالنفس عجيبه يتحدث عن انهم
سلميين وتم جرهم والتكفيريين وكاننا فقط
سنفرغ لتسليم بلادنا مقابل ترديده لهذه
الكلمات سلميه وتكفير وما شابه اعد سؤالك
لو سمحت لا انا انا سالت عن ابعاد هذه
التطورات العسكريه الخطيره الان في صنعاء
اتحدث فقط عن ما يحدث في الساعات الاخيره
قصف مبنى التلفزيون ربما مهاجمه نقطه
عسكريه بالقرب من من المطار وفي المقابل
الجيش اليمني يعني يبدي بعض الرخاوه ان صح
التعبير وحدات منه انسحبت اليوم من شملان
شمالي صنعاء هل هذا يعني ان الجيش خرج
نسبيا عن سيطره الرئيس هناك اختراقات هناك
مشاكل في التواصل
والقياده لا لا لم يخرج عن سيطره الرئيس
هناك اختلال وليس خروجا عن السيطره هناك
اختلال في اداء الجيش بسبب تبعات الثوره
السابقه التي هي ثوره الشباب شباب الربيع
العربي الى الان تم هيكله الجيش او محاوله
هيكلته بطريقه لم تكن سويه تماما فالان ه
الاختلال هو تمظهر لتلك المحاوله في
الهيكله او او بعض اخفاقات الجيش لم يخرج
عن السيطره ولن يخرج عن السيطره جيشنا
لازال متكاملا وقويا
وسيصدقوك هناك تلميحات معلش معلش هناك
تلميحات يعني ترقى الى مستوى التصريح بان
مثلا قائد المنطقه السادسه ياتمر باوامر
الرئيس المخلوع علي عبد الله
صالح
يا سيدي الكريم يا الحبيب انا اتحدث الان
لا اريد ان نبدو امام العرب ولا امام
اليمنيين فقط يحشرنا الحوثي او يحشرنا
الاعلام العربي او يحشرنا الاعلام المحلي
في ايجاد صيغ لنات او عثرات نتفرغ بدلا من
الدفاع عن بلادنا
وا اظهار وجهه نظرنا بشان هذه الميليشيا
وبشان قدرتنا على ردعها نتفرغ فقط للبحث
عن صيغ وذرائع لما يحدث من اختلالات لدينا
وضع نحن عالقين وليعرف كل العرب نحن
اليمنيين نعاني لا نقول اننا في وضع سوي
كليه او في وضع مثالي سواء على المستوى
السياسي او على مستوى اداء الجيش على كل
المستويات نحن نعاني ونحن عالقون في فخ
لعين ميليشيا تتقدم وتريد ان تجرنا الىى
حرب طائفيه نحن نحاول باقلامنا وبكلمات
هنا ونحاول ترميم الوجود اليمني ام
بالكلمات او بالتواجد وال الافصاح عن
الشخصيه الامنيه لدينا رئيس يتخاذل ل لن
نصل معه الى التهمه العظيمه الى الان
مؤقتا ولو مراعاه للمزاج لكننا نقول ان
الجيش ربما ثم تعثرات اداريه وربما اخطا
لكن عليه بدلا من ان يتحدث اليوم لو سمحت
لي خمس
ثواني عليه قاله هؤلاء القاده طيب وضح
ساعود اليك في هذه النقطه ساعود اليك في
هذه النقطه دكتور التواتي يعني امام
المخاوف والهواجس من ان يتمدد ربما هذا
هذا الصراع
يتجاوز ربما محليته الى الجوار الاقليمي
ما تقييمكم لخطوره الموقف الان خاصه وان
بعض هذه المعارك هذا التوتر يجري مباشره
على الحدود مع السعوديه في في في محافظه
الجوف الحقيقه انه ما يفعله الحوثي منذ
الاتفاق على الفيدراليه في
صنعاء هو رفض عملي لهذه الفدراليه لانها
لا
تعطيه امتداد للجوف ولا تعطيه امتداد لحجه
لان الحجه اصبحت جزء من اقليم تهامه وهو
يريد منفذ على البحر الاحمر ويريد
منفذ على المناطق المفتوحه
والصحراويه والتي يتوقع ان فيها نفط وهي
الجوف هو في صعده منطقه جبليه
صعبه يريد ان يتمدد اكثر في المواجهه
السعوديه حتى يصل الى شروره والمناطق
الصحراويه بحيث يستطيع التعاون مع الحراك
الجنوبي والقاعده الموجودين في المحافظات
الجنوبيه بشكل او باخر ل يوسع الجبهه جبهه
الاختراق على المملكه بحيث تسفل الصحراء
وتشمل المناطق الجبليه وتشمل نجران
ويفرض هيمنه تضمن
له ليس مجرد الافتراق ولكن ايضا موارد
نفطيه يتوقع ان تكون كبيره بالذات في
النفط والغاز الغاز على وجه
التحديد ما يدل على هذه المطام
انه استطاع ان يوقف التنقيب عن النفط في
في الجوف عن طريق زعزعه الامن واختلاق
المشاكل والهجمات
حتى يجبر الشركات الصينيه والاجنبيه الا
تستمر في اعمالها
لزياده التنقيب او لاستخراج نفط يمكن ان
يغير المعادله في اليمن يحول الحكومه
المركزيه الى حكومه قويه هو لا يريد صنعاء
واؤكد على هذا هو لا يريد صنعاء هو يريد
حجه وعمران وصعده والجوف يريد الجوف حتى
يقترب
من المناطق التي ياتيه منها
الامداد عن طريق بحر العرب اللي هي
مناطق حضرموت او سبوه م
هذه خطين للامداد يمكن ان يستفيد منها هو
يستفيد منها بشكل ضئيل الان ولكن وجود
محافظه الجوف يؤذيه كثيرا لان الجوف فيها
قبائل كثيره من القبائل العربيه السنيه
المواليه للعرب السنه وبالمناسبه للاخ
معجب اقول معجب حافظ انه العرب السنه
موجودين انت
منهم ربما طائفتك تختلف ولكنهم موجودين
وهم اغلبيه في اليمن وعليك ان تتعايش معهم
وتترك الالفاظ اللي ما لها معنى تكفيريين
داعشيين هذه الالفاظ اراكم تستخدمونها
بكثره هذه الايام وهذا لا يجوز لاحد يريد
وفاقا وطنيا او يريد ان يتعايش تحت علم
واحد في دوله واحده دعني دكتور معلش دعي
دعني اسال السيد ماجب يعني ايه
هناك انطباعات عند البعض ربما يقين متزايد
بان يعني الحوثيين لهم بعد او هدف
استراتيجي اكثر من هذه المطالب بدليل ان
التحركات الاخيره اتت الى حد ما اكلها من
خلال المفاوضات هناك تنازلات تنازلات
قدمها الرئيس اليمني يعني قضيه السولار
قضيه تشكيل حكومه جديده ولكن لكن ما انتم
متهمون به او ما متهم به الحوثيون انهم
يريدون بالنهايه خلق كيان موازي يريدون
ضرب كينونه الدوله القوميه الوطنيه
المدنيه نعم دعني على عجاله من الامر ان
اعقد على ما طرحه الاستاذ نعم ما طرحه
الاستاذ الصحفي القدير محمود ياسين هذه
التحركات الشعبيه سيدي الكريم التي تصفها
بالميلي شيات هي من يتبنى اوجاع الشارع
اليمني وانا اتفق معك جيدا ان على الرئيس
عبد ربو منصور هادي سرعه اقاله اللواء علي
محسن الاحمر الذي استطاع ان يسخر الجيش
وان يستخدم الجيش لصالح حزب الاصلاح الذي
انت الان تدافع عنه واود ان اوضح للدكتور
باني انا اصلا سني ولكني اناصر حركه انصار
الله عندما يتحدثون باسم الشارع اليمني
وباوع هذا الشارع اليمني اما عن سؤالك
سيدي الكريم حول ان انصار الله يريدون ان
يوجدوا كيان موازي يضرب كينونه الدوله كما
تفضلت فان صار الله كغيرهم من اليمنيين
يبحثون عن دوله مدنيه تتسع للجميع يبحثون
عن دوله شراكه لم يجدوها عندما سيطر
الاخوان المسلمين على السلطه والحكم انصار
الله ك كل اليمنيين يبحثون عن شراكه
حقيقيه لا عن حكومه محاصصه كما هو حاصل
اليوم المبادرات والمفاوضات السياسيه حتى
اللحظه لم تصل الى المطلب الحقيقي للشارع
اليمني الذي طلب الغاء الجرعه كامله
واسقاط هذه الحكومه الذي يعترف كل الاطراف
السياسيه وكل المجتمع الدولي يعترف بفساد
هذه الحكومه ولكن لا تزال هناك مراكز قوى
ومراكز نفوذ تتمسك بهذه الحكومه لانها
مستفيده من هذه الحكومه ولانها تنهى
باقتصاد وخيرات الوطن ايضا تنفيذ مخرجات
الحوار الوطني اذا كان انصار الله يبحثون
عن ضرب كينونه الدوله اذا كانوا يبحثون عن
ايجاد دوله داخل الدوله كما يروج البعض
لماذا يطالبون بتنفيذ مخرجات الحوار
الوطني التي اتفق عليها كل القوى السياسيه
داخل مؤتمر الحوار اذا كانوا يريدون دوله
مستقله فلماذا اليوم ينزلون الى الشارع
ليطالبوا بمطالب الشارع اليمني بمطالب
الشعب انصار الله والقبائل المواليه لهم
من المسلحين المتواجدين على مداخل العاصمه
صنعاء يستطيعون ان يسقطوا العاصمه خلال
دقائق معدوده لا نقول ساعات وانما دقائق
معدوده يستطيعون اليوم ان يصلوا الى مراكز
هامه جدا داخل العاصمه صنعاء ولكنهم
انتهجوا العمل السلمي انتهجوا الطريقه
السلميه والمطار الش سنبني لاحقا على على
كلامك هذا بان هناك قدره على اسقاط
العاصمه يعني بهذه السهوله ولكن بعد فاصل
قصير نناقش بعده ما هي خيارات الحكومه
اليمنيه والقوى الداعمه لها في مواجهه
تحركات الحوثيين في صنعاء والجوف نرجو ان
تبق
[موسيقى]
مع اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش ابعاد تحركات الحوثيين في العاصمه
اليمنيه صنعاء وفي محافظه الجوف وخيارات
الحكومه اليمنيه في مواجهتهم سيد محمود
ياسين ما ردك على ما قاله ضيفي السيد معجب
بان مساله اسقاط صنعاء يعني مساله سهله
جدا هو قال في دقائق ربما يمكن اسقاط هذه
العاصمه رمز السياده
اليمنيه اطلاقا هذا جزء من الدعايا
الحوثيه وهي منذ فتره ذبت على هكذا
اطلاق شكل من استعراض القوه التي
ليست بحوزتهم لديهم ديناميت وعربات ولديهم
سلاح لكنهم لا يمتلكون القدره على اسقاط
صنعاء لا بعد ايام ولا بعد شهور ولا بعد
سنوات صنعاء اكبر من ان تلتهمها ميليشيا
ارد بجزئيه بسيطه نحن لن ك كتاب لن نمضي
بقيه سنواتنا هذه ونحن ندافع الخطر
المليشاوي في في درء تهمه اننا اصلاحي من
عدمه لقد سئمنا هذه التهمه الان هذا تهديد
لكل اليمنيين لا شان لي انا بالاصلاح ولم
اكن اصلاحيا يما انا كاتب فحسب وكاتب يمني
وارد على الاخ الذي كان يحلل قبل قليل
ويتحدث عن ان هناك سنه هو تحدث بمحبه عن
اليمن لكنه كلمه ومفرده سنه نحن لسنا سنه
ولن نكن سنه مقابل الشيعه ولن نستحدث هذا
المسمى الطائفي نحن يمنيين فحسب نحن
يمنيين ولن نكون ضمن سياق صراع يتم فرزه
وفقا لخريطه حديثه
للمنطقه تتبنى حاجه السياسه الاقليميه
وحاجه القوى الدوليه لاحداث صراع معين يتم
نقله لليمن نحن يمنيين سندافع عن بلادنا
ولن تسقط صنعاء اطلاقا الجيش سيتحرك في
الوقت المناسب وسيكون له كلمته هنا اتها
ان هذا هو الوقت المناسب معلش هناك
اتهامات للرئيس اليمني بانه هو من سمح
بالنهايه بتغول بين بين قوسين الحوثي من
خلال تقديم التنازل وراء التنازل وخاصه من
خلال اشراكهم في الحوار الوطني
والرضوخ ايضا بين قوسين لمطالبهم في كل
مره هو يبدو انه لعب لعبه اكبر من طاقته
اولا نحن
بعد رحيل علي عبد الله صالح حدث خلخله في
بنيه الدوله اليمنيه وهو لعب وهو غير متمو
لعب لعبه اكبر منه لعب ازاحه قوى وا ادخال
قوى الان وكانه ذلك الذي يلعب لعبه شطرنج
وهو مبتدئ مع الكمبيوتر نقلتين ويقوله كش
ملك لم نصل لمرحله كش ملك لكن الحوثيه
تمكنت من احداث نقله خطره اقتربت من القلب
اليمني لكنها لن تسقطه عبد ربه الان اقول
له رغم كل الذي اطلقنا من كتابات في الصحف
وفي مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي رغم كل الذي
قيل وربما اننا اطلقنا في لحظه ضب كلمه
الخيانه لكن لا يزال هناك متسع من الوقت
ولو انه ضئيل جدا لفعل شيء تحرك الان يا
سيدي قبل ان تحترق البلاد تحرك الان ليس
لصالح سنه ولا ضد شيعه ليس لصالح د مناطقي
من اليمن ولا ضد جزء تحرك لحفظ البلاد طيب
الوقت الوقت يحاصرنا الوقت يحاصرنا معلش
سعود اليك ربما في السؤال اخير دكتور علي
بن حسن التواتي الان يعني اذا ما فشلت هذه
المفاوضات هذه الوساطه ما يمكن ان يكون
لهذا الصراع من تداعيات في اليمن وفي
الجوار
الاقليمي اولا انا احيي الاستاذ محمود
ياسين على قوله باننا يمنيون وحسب وهذا ما
نتمناه انا فقط كنت ارد على من وصف فئه من
الشعب اليمني بالتكفيريين وغيره قبل هذا
وصفهم بالداعي وهذه اوصاف تطلق على اهل
السنه وم من حقي انا كعربي سني ان انبه
الاخرين ان يتعاملوا معي بوطنيه ولا
يتعاملوا معي بطائف هذا من حقي ثانيا
بالنسبه لفشل المفاوضات ان فسلت
المفاوضات وهذا ما اتوقعه
ف لن يصمد الحوثي في وجه الجيش اليمني
والقبائل اليمنيه المتحالفه وان كان يبدو
ذلك بسبب بسيط جدا انه معظم من تراهم في
صنعاء ليسوا حوثيين معظم من تراهم في
صنعاء هم محتجين على فشل الحكومه ومحتجين
على ارتفاع الاسعار ومحتجين على سوء
الخدمات فاذا ما وجدوا ان عاصمه بلادهم
ستهدد وان الحوثي يريد ان يسخرها
تسخيرات ولمصلحته اقليميه اخرى اعتقد انه
هذه المعركه لن تكون فقط معركه الحكومه
اليمنيه الانتقاليه ولكن معركه دول الخليج
العربيه وهي اولى من وجهه نظري من معركه
داعش دع معركه الحوثي وايقافه عند حده هي
معركه يجب ان تاخذ اولويه قصوى لانه اذا
تمدد الحوثي في اليمن الشمالي وبالذات في
الحدود الشماليه هذا سيهدد عمان وسيه دد
المملكه وسيه دد كافه دول علينا جبه لا
يمكن
واضح دكتور اسمح لي فقط بان اتوجه بسؤال
اخير الى السيد معجب وهو سؤال في الحقيقه
هام ومفصلي الرئيس هادي اشار هذه معلومه
يعني ومعلومه جديده اثارت جدلا كبيرا اشار
الى انه تلقى رساله عبر وسيط عماني من
الايرانيين يقولون فيها انهم قد يعني قد
ربما
يوجهون بين قوسين ايضا تعليمات الحوثيين
بتخفيف الضغط على المدخل الجنوبي لصنعاء
في حال القبول بشروط معينه هذه شروط مفصله
هي خاصه اطلاق سراح المتهمين في جهان واحد
وجه وجهان اثنين الا يدل هذا على ان
الحوثيين تحولوا الى ربما لعبه في ايدي
قوى خارجيه اقليميه بسرعه ارجوك نعم هذا
ترويج سياسي يحاول بعض الاطراف ان تحاول
بعض الاطراف ان تروج له لصنع مكاسب سياسيه
ولتحاول ابعاد الجماهير الشعبيه عن حركه
انصار الله السياسيه اليمنيه التي هي حركه
جاءت من وسط الشارع اليمني ومن اوجاع
الشارع اليمني ولا تنتمي ولا تدين الا
لهذا الشارع اليمني الحر ولا اعتقد ان
هناك حقيقه لهذه التسريبات او لهذه
المعلومات واذا كان الاخوه الايرانيين
قادرين ان يتوسطه للتخفيف على الضغط
فلياتوا لتخفيض اسعار الجرعه او لياتوا
لاسقاط هذه الحكومه لا اعتقد ان الاخوه في
ايران يستطيعون ان يفعلوا شيء امام هذه
الجماهير لا لا تستطيع حتى حركه انصار
الله اليوم ان تعيد هذه الجماهير اليوم
الى بيوتها دون ان تتحقق المطالب الثلاثه
التي خرج الشعب من اجلها اليوم الجماهير
تحركها مطالب شعبيه حقيقيه واضحه لا
يستطيع احد ان يتدخل امام هذه المطالب اذا
لم تتحقق اشكرك اشكرك سيد عبد الحفظ معجب
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من بيروت اشكر سيد
محمود ياسين الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من
صنعاء ومن جده عبر سكايب الكاتب والمحلل
الاستراتيجي الاستراتيجي الدكتور علي بن
حسن التواتي شكرا جزيلا لكم بهذا تنتهي
هذه الحلقه من برنامج مورا الخبر نلتقي
باذن الله في قراءه جديده في موار خبر
جديد الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء